jennifer this garden from cs and she's
done
work on bioinformatics and look forward
hearing the topic
thanks uh so i'm gonna apologize on two
fronts one i said to when ben first
asked me i said i don't work in this
area and she said this paper talk about
this paper and so it's not quite fitting
um but i'm hoping just that i in any
case my goal here is to get you just
interested in this problem and and maybe
how i think about it as a computer
scientist which is machine learning for
protein engineering and then the second
thing i'm going to apologize for the
thing she asked me to talk about i had a
bit of an emergency this morning and i
didn't get that much of it in so
and i was in the middle of getting the
deck ready and then something happened
so it's maybe a bit more scattered than
usual but please stop me if you have any
uh questions or concerns uh and and so
okay so let's get started so basically
generally uh i started this area around
four years ago when i moved to uc
berkeley from microsoft research where i
spent all my years and i'm sort of my
thinking is evolving on this and some of
the projects my group does are pure
computational and uh the point of this
was to lead you up from our pie in the
sky machine learning thinking to what
we're actually doing with some wet lab
collaborators on campus here and what
we've managed to achieve but i squeezed
very little of that in um but so let me
just motivate even the idea of
re-engineering proteins probably when i
tell most people now about proteins can
i close this i feel like i can't see um
people think of alpha fold two and they
immediately think that what i work on is
predicting structure from sequence which
is completely not what i work on and i
will leave those massive engineering
tasks to deep mind too uh to deep mind
to alpha full two two deep mind uh of
course whatever progress they make feeds
into the problems we think about and i
think they've made some really stunning
progress i'm not going to talk about it
here and i'm not even going to talk
about structure prediction at all
i'm going to talk
more about using machine learning data
to train a supervised model and then use
that model to design proteins in a kind
of abstract way and so but there's two
ways people think of
or do protein engineering one is to take
existing proteins
and then try to kind of change them
re-engineer them to achieve the purpose
they want so proteins are like kind of
the workhorse of
almost all of biology so this one
fluoresces naturally but people engineer
it to fluoresce more or at a different
wavelength and that might just sound
like a fun thing to do but actually this
is like really important it gets used
all over academia and in industrial wet
labs as well uh of course everyone's
heard of crispr cas9 this is a protein
here that comes in the pac-man it pulls
the dna apart makes a cut and then
enables you to edit it and people are
also engineering that cast mind to do
all kinds of things like not to cut or
to cut in different places and so forth
so the one i'm
very excited now about for many reasons
including that i have a very close
collaborator on campus david shaffer and
his group who's very interested in using
viruses um as mechanisms to deliver gene
therapies which i'm sure most people
here have heard about and so ostensibly
the focus of this talk is how to use
machine learning to do this and i
promise i will say something about it
but i'm going to lead you through some
of the things we've been thinking about
before i get there
um
all right and so i'm out of breath i
literally sprinted here i didn't know i
didn't know it was a 25 minute walk from
where i was i'm also a bit out of breath
but okay so uh i'm not going to go
through the very basics i'm going to
assume people know what amino acids are
and that a protein is a string of a meat
can be encoded by a string of amino
acids there's an alphabet of size 20.
you can see examples from that alphabet
here that are drawn from our own
alphabet of 26 and basically any string
is syntactically a correct protein but
it might not fold it might not be
functional and in fact if you just
randomly generate strings from this
20 amino acid alphabet it's very
unlikely they're going to even fold up
into a structurally
stable
3d thing which is generally required for
that protein to be of any utility
and so this is of course a vast
combinatorial space proteins are often
you know in the hundreds of length of
this uh alphabet and so you can see just
the sort of the sheer combinatorics get
you near the number of atoms in the
universe um just for like the number of
possible proteins for a fixed length
that is within the you know normal size
of proteins this is a huge huge space
and so a lot of protein engineering is
basically like how do i navigate the
space to get the thing i want to get
when it's so massively large
and of course my interest in this is to
say although so this is the main way
it's done right now in the wet lab
without any computation and my goal
since i came to uc berkeley was
basically to think about what are ways
that we can leverage machine learning to
make this more effective um so but who
here's heard of directed evolution
it got the nobel prize a few years ago
um by these three folks and it's
actually it's sort of so simple and so
easy to explain um i don't know how many
nobel prizes that's true for no wonder
actually i think it's it's but so it's
literally self-explanatory who who has
never heard of it but thinks they can
explain it from the name
someone here but you're being shy plus i
don't have time to let you talk okay so
uh so the way it works is you have to
start with a single protein that already
you know about and has like the seed of
the thing you care about so suppose you
want this protein to fluoresce bright
yellow so you need it to fluoresce at
least a little bit at some wavelength
and you can think of that as like a good
parameter initialization for a machine
learning model
because it turns out there's not you
can't just start anywhere they're like
the initialization's super important
here at the moment probably forever also
and so suppose you start with that thing
and now you have to decide essentially
in regular evolution like the fitness is
like our ability to reproduce and be
stay alive long enough to reproduce and
also be um healthy enough to get our
children to get to an age where they can
helpfully reproduce right like that's
natural evolution in directed evolution
we're directing it because we're
actually specifying the thing we want
selection for and so we actually going
to create a population of things through
some diversification mechanism in the
lab we'll start with that one protein
and then basically you can imagine just
like um at every position with some
probability you're going to mutate it at
random such that on the whole there's
some set of um maybe two three mutations
from the original one you started with
and that gives you that's a
diversification step which gives you a
variant pool
and then from there you decide what you
care about and you select out the ones
that are not behaving very well
according to that property so if it's
not fluorescing at all you know you you
have to measure the thing you care about
that's and that's actually a big
bottleneck here because typically it's
actually very hard to measure what you
care about in biology but fluorescence
is quite easy so you take let's say the
top 10
according to the thing you care about
which you measure or at least a proxy of
and you throw out the rest and you keep
a pool of improved variants and then you
keep going until you hit some sort of
convergence and hopefully when you
converge you have what you want
um
and uh and so this people this is very
simple and so you know there's a whole
at the level i've described it but it's
a lot of complexity and how you measure
what you want and also how to think
about that diversification step these
are very important hard problems but uh
abstracted for us kind of computational
people it's quite straightforward
so right so my goal was to say can we um
work synergistically with this kind of
idea and either get the same results
with fewer iterations
and that can be super important because
so my collaborator he works with like
non-human primates in the lab and like
that's like has ethical
you know concerns and costs and all
kinds of stuff so if you can just have
the number of iterations from six to
three on this like really you know kind
of crazy experiments that's like really
really useful
uh and then alternatively there's a
number of things that just can't be done
like this people just don't have success
and they get to a convergence of this
algorithm and they don't have what they
want and so i'd like to both make it
faster and i'd like to be able to get us
to places that we can't currently get to
and so when i first started uh working
on this i used to say there's two places
you might think to put in machine
learning here on the face of it and the
very first obvious one is to replace the
screening assay this thing where you
measure the fluorescence or the binding
or whatever with a machine learning
predictive model
and so i definitely if you want to do
something smart in the space you're
going to have to do that i used to say i
don't care about prediction this is
commodity by now go get your data go get
your scikit-learn and like train it and
if it works it works if it doesn't it
doesn't like i'm not i'm not going to
have my lab focused on building
predictive models but i stand corrected
in the sense that it turns out there's a
bunch of interesting problems here about
how to pick suitable inductive biases
for these models for proteins and also
how to think about uncertainty and
whether it's calibrated for these
especially as you move towards
extrapolation space so i won't talk very
much about those depending
wow
how far we get do i get extra time
because we started late okay so what
time do i have until
okay
um so
the one i got more interested in
initially but these of course are
interrelated is like if you think about
what directed evolution is doing it's
doing like a random greedy walk right
it's like let's randomize to a pool
variance and then move to the best one
and then do again and so you can you
know kind of think rigorously about what
kinds of functions you could have
success on if you move in that kind of
grand greedy stochastic way but it
stands to reason that if we could
understand something more about
particular landscapes that we're moving
through that maybe we could do smarter
moves than these kinds of greedy
stochastic moves
uh and so that's how i kind of first got
interested but now i'm interested in in
all of this and much more
so let me tell you a little bit about
the story as it started for my group
when i moved here with my first student
david brooks
so we started saying suppose we had a
little bit of supervised data and we
could build a model and this is actually
what happens for the the actual
instantiation of this with gene therapy
that i'll tell you about they gave us
some data and they said this is what we
care about uh and in general you care
about many things actually especially
when you get into therapeutics you don't
typically care just as it hit the target
i want you care about toxicity clearance
from the body and so forth but i'm just
generally so far we're gonna usually
just think about one property now
suppose you have this data and you train
some model i've put a neural network
here but it could be whatever
however in practice these days uh neural
networks actually work really well on a
lot of problems
uh and now the idea is that instead of
training the model as usual as usual
i want to assume i've trained the model
and i want to specify the output that i
the desired output like maybe binds this
target high enough and using the already
trained network i want to in a sense
learn the inputs that will give me what
i want
and so on the face of it this is just a
pure optimization problem where i'm
optimizing the function defined by the
neural network
um but actually this is actually it's
and people have thought about it this
way and published papers and they're and
they're more or less complete nonsense
so why are they complete nonsense any
ideas
am i allowed to drink
is this like legal can i do that
so
uh right this explains it what's the
problem so
uh there's an analogy in computer vision
uh to the problem i've described the
problem i've described is how do i get a
protein that has the property i want and
the analogy is as many years ago in
computer vision people would train these
massive state-of-the-art neural networks
and they'd say i want to know what my
neural network thinks a banana is when
it um even though it also seems to know
what a zebra and an apple and a pair of
blah blah so what they do is they have a
multi-class thing for each class they're
in their thing they set all the outputs
to zero except the banana node to one so
it's different because i care about
regression they're doing classification
but it's basically the same and then
they do back propagation to
do gradient descent to minimize an
objective that gives them the best
highest banana output and they ask what
that image looks like so so what does
that image look like
it looks like abstract art
uh so you say it's not crazy right like
i can see
how this might make sense it has some
curves it has some yellow
um but you know if i were to send this
to the 3d printer this is not gonna like
no one's gonna think this is a banana
right so so what has gone wrong
essentially is that we have these
pathological blind spots and these
highly over parameterized models
probably even in very simple models
actually but especially in these over
parameterized models and so what's
interesting is this is not an
adversarial like it's not a game it's
not adversarial when i design a protein
right i'm just saying i want my protein
to have this property but it actually
kind of behaves in an adversarial manner
because you're pushing it to the corners
of the space to maximize this thing and
so sort of in effect it behaves almost
as though it's like adversarial getting
to weird corners that just don't make
sense
this is actually in some like like all
real problems this is an impossible
problem to deal with but i think one of
our contributions is to one recognize it
and think about it and at least propose
some formalisms that would allow us um
to reasonably mitigate it but i think
progress can always be made and at the
end of the day you want a formalism that
enables you to think cleanly about this
and bring to bear your uh your domain
knowledge
so
so
that's sort of how i got into this space
of machine learning and protein
engineering and so i'm going to this i
totally switched the talk around and
then i ran here so i let's see if i can
stay uh understand my own logic of these
slides but let me just tell you if you
think about the problem that way like
let me reiterate and explain a bit more
what some of the problems that emerge
here and this is part of the reason i
like working at this intersection
because you know there's all the
standard problems in nlp and vision but
i feel like when you go into these
scientific domains you get to think
about things that sometimes also have
application and analogy there but you
get to think about slightly different
problems and so kind of the key issue
here right is this natural tension
between how do i take a trained model
and kind of let's suppose i want to
maximize a property and i'm basically
asking it to extrapolate and i think we
all know that we can't extrapolate like
arbitrarily and that's essential these
pathological corners that emerge and so
there's the question is how do i
navigate this sort of ability to
extrapolate somewhere useful um by
understanding where i trust this model
and how can i think about where i trust
this model and so we often see these
sort of gaussian process regression
curves like this where the um i only
learned these terms this year epistemic
uncertainty i had to write them on my
whiteboard because i couldn't remember
what they were but the epistemic
uncertainty is the uncertainty you get
just by being far away from the data
right usually we think of like the
sensor noise instrument noise which is
the allio territory correct me if i got
them wrong i think this is right and so
in some sense we really care about
estimating the epistemic uncertainty in
some reasonable manner and leveraging it
throughout this process
um so i'm just listing here these are
basically things we started to do in my
group that touch on all of these um
through various of my students and so uh
this is you know of course related to
causality if i had the true causal model
this wouldn't be an issue but i never
have the true causal model and we've not
started to think about this in terms of
methodology from causality but there you
know perhaps there's opportunities there
uh and okay right so this is also
related to this epistemic uncertainty uh
that i mentioned and like how can we
estimate it well and use it uh to do
these these kinds of things
uh and then as i mentioned i'm not i
might i might i have one slide versions
of all these at the end if i have time
which i probably won't um
but uh also this as i mentioned if i i'm
gonna invert this model but i'm also the
one that gets to build it then i might
want to think and we started to think a
lot about this what are good ways to
think of inductive biases for these
models and just as an example if you
think about dropout or convolution or
like these are all inductive biases
right but in proteins are these discrete
inputs and and we know actually that
it's sparse in the um
features which are just the single amino
acids and pairs of amino acids and
triplets of amino acids sort of
first and second and third order and if
you try to regularize at the level of
the parameters you can never capture
that and so there's this sort of um uh
it's hard to think about what's the
right way to induce these inductive
biases when i parameterize it with this
giant neural network that doesn't map to
that
um
and then so this is the one i'm i'm
gonna
try to talk about as it pertains to this
collaboration we've been doing for a few
years which is that the way i've
described it so far is to say i'm going
to tell you what outputs i want and you
go find me a sequence right
and so of course everything's imperfect
and in practice what we want is to hedge
our bets and have a set of sequences
there and so there's actually one of my
students is very interested in actually
trying to characterize how we should
think about hedging our bets in this
sequence which is very related to batch
active learning
um
but
but it turns out that in protein
engineering we cannot often go back to
the collaborator and say please you know
print this particular sequence
because what they actually do is instead
of just creating individual sequences
like you know you could imagine i have
an excel sheet and i say please make
this sequence and this sequence and this
sequence like they they don't typically
well they sometimes operate that way and
it's certainly
almost certainly the way of the future
but there's a lot of very interesting
things being done now where it's more
constrained than that and so what you
actually do is you design a distribution
over the sequences and the thing you get
to give back to your wet lab
collaborators are the parameters of that
distribution and i'll say more what i
mean about that in a second but if you
hear the word library design like a
library in biology is basically a
distribution over sequences defined by
some knobs that you can tell your
collaborator to set in this particular
way
uh right and so this is the culmination
of several years of work um with with
david schaefer's lab and and bonnie the
postdoc and david my first student where
we're using
some of these ideas to actually advance
uh some of the important parts of
aav engineering for gene therapy and
i'll explain
more um ah okay so
i uh i think i already said this but
right so library design is a
distribution design and that's to be
contrasted with designing individual
sequences which is the way you would
think about this or an individual image
instead it's like a distribution over
images and that's when we cannot
feasibly specify each individual protein
in the library
and so right so let me instantiate that
with actually the real example that we
use which you'll see is super super
simple so this is what we actually get
to do in the real life exam example that
i'm going to tell you about and i mean
this is so real this is actually like
stuff that's through fda approval for
blindness therapies this isn't like real
we did something in the wet lab here on
campus this is really um impactful stuff
so in this case uh
it's gonna be a sequence of length seven
from the amino acid amino acid alphabet
and the only thing we can tell our
collaborators is the marginal
distribution of each amino acid at each
position
and so
that's actually a pretty rudimentary
control knob and yet it's actually good
enough to do some really important
things
uh and that's that's just the one we're
focused on there's quite a large um set
of these that you could think about as
well
and sometimes there's a trade trade-off
between cost uh and scale so to the
extent we want more precise control
usually we cannot generate as much or uh
or sometimes measure as much and so even
if the technology is there to do
something more specific we don't always
do that
it's true here in particular so if i'm
interested in library design and i'm
thinking about
protein engineering in the context of
this sort of invert my model
while taking into account the
pathological areas of the space it's
useful to think about that optimization
problem uh in a different way than you
might usually so how do we usually write
an optimization problem you might
normally think this is the neural
network uh point prediction or something
based on its cumulatively cumulative
density function to account for
uncertainty
and then you might say i want to
maximize this thing so i'm now going to
search through protein space where x is
a protein
and so what we did actually before we
were doing library design for other
reasons but it turns out this is the
perfect thing to do for library design
is we said instead of searching over
individual sequences let's search over a
distribution of sequences and i think if
this is now like a spotlight in protein
space so it's a bit of an abuse i tend
to think of it as like a gaussian it's
an abuse because of course this is
discrete but i think it's a helpful
visual to think i'm going to do some
optimization that starts off with some
gaussian and i'm going to move it around
instead of following a trajectory of
individual proteins
and uh and when i convert the problem to
this it becomes an expectation
uh
with respect to that distribution where
i'm trying to find the theta which is
sort of like the mean and the covariance
uh and i'm going to move it around and
change the mean and covariance to get to
a part of protein space that has the
property i want and then i can sample
from it
so
can you just do this so i'm not going to
go through any proofs but you can
probably see somewhat intuitively that
when this distribution um parameter
parameterized distribution if it's high
enough capacity to put all of its mass
on the single protein that maximizes
things then they're equivalent doesn't
mean you can find it it just means the
formulation is equivalent and so you can
always do this
and you might actually one of the nice
things and i'll get to this in a second
ah well i won't say it yet because it's
on the next slide uh but does this make
sense so we're converting the problem
from just
searching for an x to searching for a
distribution over x and now originally
we weren't doing library design and we
were actually just
kind of using this for for for reasons
i'll mention a second but if you have a
library that has particular parameters
you can just actually model exactly
those parameters here so it's also
convenient right i can just say only
allow this distribution to have the
parameters for the marginal uh
distribution at each position and then i
naturally get out the parameters
is p a known parameter distribution
probability distribution so
how does it look like is it based on the
library that you are looking at or so
this is just i mean so if x if sequences
were real valued i could think of it as
a gaussian since it's since sequences of
amino acids are not it could be a hidden
markov model it could be a variational
auto encoder it could be a mixture of
hidden markup models it could be
multinomial
um
things like this so you have a
description of the probability
distribution p is that so we're going to
find the parameters that opt
that status we're going to try to find
the parameters that maximize this
expression okay yeah
so that's like you start with some
distribution over proteins and as you
i'm not going to go into too many
details about the algorithm but it moves
around and then it converges
um
so so this is nice because it's sort of
directly relevant to library design
because this is essentially how we think
about libraries in biology if we can map
the experimental design knobs to some uh
parameters that we can actually fit
uh it's also there's some other reasons
that it's nice the one maybe that i'll
highlight that i think is just kind of
cool and the reason we first started to
do this is that i've actually brought in
the language of probability into
optimization and like in a kind of weird
way and so you're like okay well why
why is that real like does that bias
something and so i won't go into too
many details but it turns out once we're
in the language of probability it
enables us to formally and coherently
bring in domain knowledge to help us
rein in uh from going into those
pathological regions and that's actually
why we first started to use this
and in a sense you can define like
probabilistic trust regions
uh based on
for like an example would be there's
huge databases of all known proteins
that stably fold so if you could build
some sort of
people can build a density model over
those now you have a density over all
known proteins that fold which is a
pretty good way to rein in your
exploration to prevent it from going
pretty crazy places
um
so
so we we have a paper out where we
explore the it's a icml paper where we
kind of get into this and in particular
how to think about these soft trust
regions to mitigate the abstract banana
problem
uh and i won't i won't go into it it's
an iterative algorithm has some few
challenges and it has uh some some nice
intuitive uh correspondence to directed
evolution itself which i won't go into
and it has some connections to some
other technical areas so let me just get
because i'm running out of time to what
what uh ben said could you maybe it'd be
nice to talk about this so so basically
we've been thinking a lot about all of
these ideas and kind of picking one off
at a time in sort of pie in the sky
methodological papers that i think of as
as uh as almost just thought papers but
they have empirics to back them and i
don't trust anything until i'm actually
doing something real and so that's this
has been a multi-year project uh with
many rounds of experiments a ton of
discussion to understand each other and
we finally got the pre-print up just
about a month or two ago
uh which you can check out and so this
is all centered on gene therapy using
the adeno associated virus aav there's a
picture here it's actually a single
protein that gets repeated um in a sort
of symmetric space and the thing we get
to engineer you can't really see because
the resolution's bad here but the little
red bit is a seven amino acid length
insertion into the capsid which is like
the outside of the protein and they they
identified this position as a place
where if you just change the seven amino
acids there you get quite wildly
different results for things you care
about so in some sense it's a good place
to induce variation to try to achieve
all kinds of engineering goals
um
right and so what is gene therapy it's
basically you want to use this virus you
want to put in the imagine you're
missing some enzyme that you need to
like live or live well and so you want
to deliver that enzyme to some
particular tissue that's missing it then
you need to basically create it put it
in the virus and then you need the virus
to to infect exactly the right cells and
not the wrong cells and that's kind of
one of the main ways that this gets used
for gene therapy
and so there's actually quite a number
of interesting engineering opportunities
here and we tackled the very first one
which is at the sort of root of all that
follows when you use it in this manner
it has to do with packaging
and so the way people do these libraries
i think it's on the next slide
um
so right so the the
this is this thing i already explained
to you is we're going to get to design
the probability distribution at each
position over the 20 amino acids
uh and then they're going to put that in
and it's going to appear in all these
repeating units and depending what's
there it will uh actually not even be
viable it won't even fold up into a
reasonable capsule it's just complete
garbage or it will fold up and have
different properties it will infect this
cell in the eye or it won't it'll in
fact it'll go through the blood-brain
barrier or it won't and things like this
and um right and so they actually dave
has a company uh that's just gone
through it's gone through fda approval
as i said and it's actually to help with
like a blindness disease in the back of
the eye and they had to engineer it to
get to the back of the eye and so the
problem is the state-of-the-art library
they use for this
uh so what they do is they create like
this library that has this huge
diversity something like 10 to the six
variants and then they screen it for to
get to the eye but actually half that
library is completely wasted because it
doesn't even fold up and function and so
in some sense they've like lost half
their ability to find good things and
they've wasted this sort of precious uh
ability to measure things and that's
just because they don't know how to
design a library such that it has like
what do you want you want great
diversity um in order to be able to have
as much sort of raw material that has
some chance of getting to the cell you
want but you also want it to be
functional
in some very general level that's a
precursor for all downstream criteria
and so the challenge we had was how can
we get a library that packages in a
sense twice as well as the state of the
art while maintaining the same diversity
um
so i'm i think i'm out of time so i'm
just going to try to very quickly
um tell you
uh
how we did this
um so the first thing we do is they
generate with the standard
state-of-the-art library that actually
wastes half of itself we build a
predictive model and we check in the lab
that this predictive model actually
works it actually does what we think and
then we um make use of kind of this
optimization i told you about but we add
an entropy term to it to control the
entropy and then we can trace out a
pareto optimal frontier that's trading
off this um the uh diversity of the
library with the overall expectation
that it can actually package and
function sort of generally be fit and so
the library that state of the art is
down here is like complete which is like
just crap it's like half of it is wasted
and then so then now we can start to
rationally think about how to pick a
good library and so that's that's
essentially what we've done we picked a
library and i don't think i have the
numbers here but we can show that in a
downstream selection that had nothing to
do with anything here uh because it was
for a specific cell type we can infect
that cell type in the brain about 10
times better than they could with the
regular current state-of-the-art library
and so the idea is to get a generally
good library for different downstream
tasks and what and we showed that for
one of those downstream tasks that we've
not optimized it for we do much much
better
um
okay so sorry i threw a lot at you i
definitely don't have time to go through
anything else but if you're interested
this is some recent stuff
from my group um
so uh
and i'll just say uh yeah i've been here
at cal for four years and i'm so glad to
have all my amazing grad students thank
you
thank you jennifer so we need two more
chairs and we'll have a panel and can
get all the questions for you
the other